ma io non ho mai notato io c'ho
veramente le sopracciglia grosse ei
partiti ragazzi venite qui sono video
sono vari j oggi sono tanti sul mio
fichissimo a nord 10 perché ci sono dei
fighissimi giochi da provare a voi
lasciate un paio ancora che non avevo
fatto
let's go ma lei ragazzi non mi fiderò
mai più di me stesso delle applicazioni
che skype sono sul mono golf e chiedimi
scrive giampiero ma sei un pezzo di m i
miei amici mi mi adorano ragazzi siate
sempre gli idoli dei vostri amici right
and play
questo qua è un altro di giochi che
avevo scaricato in teoria dovrebbe
essere abbastanza semplice si tratta di
golf centrare il buco ci riesco da dio
ma che musicaccia sto gioco la musica
più strane del mondo sono un fenomeno mi
sono scoperto un dio del golf no porca
che ci ho creduto ma in una botta sola
devo fare centro sono accadute cose va
bene ma è che figo ma quindi puoi fare
solo all in one cioè buca in uno ma
fighissimo nostro gioco veramente perché
l'ho fatto non scoprirlo prima e geniale
matematico gol subiti air france ma è
abbastanza figo fatto per telefono
se ci fosse il multiplayer i sta roba
sarebbe ancora meglio per ora questo
ruolo
gli uccelli john locke adesso questi ti
spingono in varie direzioni sto
malissimo
e vabbè non fate domande grazie rai
ok o cos'è cos'era a ho fatto uno screen
non scherzavo tutto calcolato tutto ok
ok non ok
ogni tanto mi sorprendo di me stesso in
alcune robe altre volte non faccio
pagare
dunque io ragazzi golf lodo non so
perché mi piace giocare a golf e mi
metterà ecco in questo video vi
dimostrerò che io anche di persona so
giocare molto bene a golf
a far vedere se questa è facile no tua
madre a ma cosa sono sti cosi bianchi
sono cose in più che puoi prendere ma
che ne so io sono lo dite sì però sono
scarso come la morte rega devo andare
dritto e basta non capita mai quando
giochi ancor più
no
ei new challenge unlock ma lasciamo
perdere le challenge che jellyfish e va
così sporco demonio lo sapevo no non è
vero
porca vacca è bello sto gioco perché far
cognata potrete sclerare mentre siete a
lavoro oa scuola visto che vi consiglio
sempre i modi migliori vivere nonno
palle restanti a perché funziona palle
sto gioco c'è nel senso cioè un tot di
palle
a chi devo guardare le pubblicità devo
guardare sto tipo svogliato di vivere
per avere le palle
c'è per avere delle palle devo rompermi
le mie chiaro l'ex
[Musica]
questo è bellissimo punto interrogativo
però fatemi capire una roba se io
finisco le palle finisce proprio tutto
mi dove della pubblicità porco demonio
st acquah 2 l'ultima palla buono buono
vai vai vai va bene l'ultima regata ma
fan cuore tua sorella
no dai non mi fai paura della pubblicità
che palle
adesso non mi fa neanche più a me la
fanno anche più guardaremo ma vanno a
quindi è un gioco che arriva più lontano
chiaro non avevo capito quindi mi farei
partire tutta la capobello questa vela
risparmio magari taglio che dice i like
men porca vacca soli non riesco a farlo
anche prima era difficile anno eco sono
arrivati vivono a quello del coniglio
bene sono fatta non mi ricordo che
dov'era arrivato ragazzi però più o meno
qui ok
in teoria dovrei aver ecco qua qua ero
arrivato qua che era difficilissimo
oggi i knew record grazie a dio sono
arrivato ragazzi che o cinque palle che
non è male
ma vediamo se riesco a fare qualcosa di
decente
allora siamo arrivati a dei punti in cui
devo meditare ok siamo delle parti
credo che adesso salti la palla se vacua
giusto molto chiaro quindi ci sono le
ventole ci vorrei sapere il record
mondiale di questo gioco quant'è cioè
finisce per un po immaginano no dai
la sorella morta ieri va bene non so
neanche come faccio a far certe robe si
e scassata la palla va bene no sono
messi già che mi son dimenticato che non
puoi ritoccarla dinho sarebbe bello no
ho mica posso avere così sfiga e questo
potrebbe essere un problema
ecco mi fa rivede la pubblicità voglio
vedere lo chef tony perfetto va bene
aridaje sto tizio che ho comunque
considerazioni a caldo etico l'unico
problema sono le pubblicità cioè nel
senso sarebbe più figo secondo me se non
ripartisse ogni volta all'inizio tipo
flat libero apposito floppy perde che
nel si può giocare ancora però vabbè
lasciamo perdere
roma non è possibile era buono ok dove
minchia è finita o mariga mustaparta
difficilissima o ragazzi sta diventando
veramente difficile
calmi tutti calvin harris svevo ho
capito ho capito porco demonio
un po va bene
da ieri è possibile ma vero ho mica
prima era veramente da atroce come
faccio a prendere quelle se va detto la
sorella le piglia 1 gli uccelli in
giallo o flipper
[Musica]
non ho capito ma va bene bellissima
questa tutto calcolato per carità ok no
grazie che anzi a rivivere ti prego ti
prego ti prego già che c'è una palla
sola porco demonio morto ieri una palla
c'avevo dai zio fa il serio parte che
secondo me some andò così
ok mi stavo già incazzando cos'è sta
roba
bene no ok che culo
la mia vita così
di poco
quindi vuol dire che adesso non posso
più fare niente ma il menù è stato
fighissimo per quello che ho provato è
stato film a vedi che ci stanno e
challenge 1 su 10 12
ma su quelle di prima ma tu sorella a
tempo le di fare ma sto male che ansia
nuova personalissimo ma tipo le
verifiche di matematica che già se mi
davi tutto il tempo del mondo faceva
cagare uguale col tempo è difficilissimo
regata riceva ci manca solo che poi non
prendo il punto oddio grazie va bene
premo l'altra c'è questa tempo è un
casino regalano riesca a fare neanche
normalmente ok sono già alla seconda
buca sono a metà se va beh se non ha
fatto neanche un pezzo è difficilissimo
ma chi è che ha inventato sto gioco
satana e mi ci sto impegnando è ancora
dietro orco demonio porco demonio 2
ragazzo quindi ragazzi abbiamo capito
che tanto a golf ci so fare l'importante
è che non mi rompono le balle col tempo
quello è un problema che ci ho sempre
avuto ragazzi spero credo vi sia
piaciuto cosa mi piace anche a bari sto
cercando descrizione senza del city sky
tree e non ci vediamo ad una prossima
buca o delle prossime palle da ragazzi
[Musica]